I'm here I'm back with the amazing Tyler
Posey and
I am so excited because I've got
scissors and I'm not afraid
and Tyler's gonna let me shave his
mustache all right have you done this
before no I like your Technique
you're a pro I oh my God tell me if I
get anywhere near your skin okay
tell me before I start cutting now made
in Manhattan right I'm sorry if I'm
nervous and excited JLo she's she's
incredible she you were in made in
Manhattan when I was just a boy she's
the most professional other than you do
you like the sweetest and really care
for me like her own child before she had
kids and so it was uh I really felt like
she bought me an Xbox it's kind of nice
to see you with a different shape sure
yeah I haven't shaved it oh wow it's so
short right
oh my god wow you did a great job
there we go okay here we go
I'm ready we're crossing landmarks
whenever we get with each other we're
always having cool moves
wow I believe
that because of my trimming that this is
doing much better but you know no I
think you're right how's the nacho
cheese brass going beautiful I love it
now I just want to show you this is the
halfway point
[Applause]
wow look at that
technically exactly I got out of hand I
was worried that there was going to be
like a bird living in there when you
started shaving well when you said all
the food coagulates in there it does so
I don't know what kind of stuff is going
to be in there so what do you and and
Femme have coming up what are you guys
looking forward to doing what's what's
2023 like for you guys we have a few
songs coming out
um we wrote a song that ends the Teen
Wolf credits oh my God
she's she's she has an album coming out
oh
she has an album she has an album coming
out
you know
and more love we got a lot of love and
puppies you have puppies well we they're
all dogs but we call them puppies we
love them look at that what do you think
God that's crazy
[Applause]
well everybody
my very best of them and all my love to
you Teen Wolf the movie which is
breaking records is now streaming on
Paramount plus get it while it's hot
[Music]